speaking of which let's get back out to
8 news now investigator Vanessa Murphy
who was at the press conference with
Clark County Registrar Joe Gloria just
moments ago a Vanessa good afternoon to
you what stood out to you from what Mr
Gloria had to say
[Music]
well John Registrar of Voters Joe Gloria
started off the press conference calling
out former president Donald Trump for
his comments uh calling the voting
system here corrupt saying it gives time
to cheat Gloria is saying Trump is
misinformed about the law and election
processes here he says he couldn't go
faster even if he wanted to that the
workers here can't go faster even if
they wanted to All Eyes on Nevada
everyone wondering why it's taking so
long to tally these votes and count
these ballots he says he's simply
following the law he's following
deadlines there are certain days that he
has to follow so he provided some
numbers he says today
626 ballots were received through the
mail and he expects that number to drop
each day he also says more than seven
thousand ballots have to be cured what
does that mean signature curing is when
a ballot is received a mail ballot and
either the signature doesn't match
what's on file or it doesn't have a
signature so they are reaching out to
voters there is a list on the Clark
County website with names and addresses
of the voters who that affects we'll put
that on our website but again he says
the work is continuing here and they're
moving as fast as they can they don't
want to be too fast because they want
those results to be accurate John back
to you all right Vanessa thank you very
much we'll catch up with you later on in
further newscast again about 200 people
working there at the election
headquarters in North Las Vegas thank
you Vanessa